[music playing]
Zack, Frank, Nehemiah--
congratulations.
You've made it into the
final round of competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
four five days to recreate an
iconic weapon from history.
The Nzappa zap.
Jazz.
All right,
bladesmiths, good luck.
We'll see you in five days.
Let's do this.
Uh-huh.
[rock music]
ZACK LEWIS: Today we're
here in Sonora, California--
here to make an Nzappa zap.
Let's see how this goes.
I can't fit it in
here, so I might have
to do this thing old-fashioned.
To be truthfully honest,
I'm scared [bleep]-- less.
My master had a
personal emergency.
He had to leave the competition,
and now I'm stranded
here doing this on my own.
Just got to keep it together.
It's amazing.
I made it this far by myself.
But I'm going to
give it my all--
give 110%-- and
see what I can do.
There we go!
Today it's my turn.
I got to turn this square piece
of hot metal into a blade.
Nehemiah split it down
the middle of the night
before so that I can pull that
apart, and there's my blade.
Zack better be
bringing his game!
The charcoal forge is one of the
most interesting ways to heat
treat, and what I'm
looking for is an even
red color all the way across.
That's the right
color, Nehemiah.
NEHEMIAH BROUSSEAU: Yep.
[rock music]
Now, let's hear how
this thing sounds.
[scraping on blade]
Awesome.
NEHEMIAH BROUSSEAU: [whistles]
It's hard.
Incredible.
[rock music]
Day three-- and I'd like to
be a little further than I am.
I want this thing to be
perfect before I quench.
[music playing]
I'll go ahead and heat up
my oil little bit here.
If I want to be "Forged
in Fire" champion,
I got to pull out
all the tricks.
I figure I got to
preheat this stuff.
You won't have it
around 200 degrees.
Never had that going on.
It's really getting a
little bit out of hand--
kind of getting to an
uncontrollable fire.
I'm a little nervous.
I have never felt
anxiety like this before.
It's really getting a
little bit out of hand.
I need that [bleep] Stop sign.
Kind of getting to an
uncontrollable fire.
[rock music]
[laughs] Luckily, that worked.
I didn't want to have the
fire department out here.
Now I can quench my blade.
[rock music]
FRANK ALLEN WREN II:
Today is my last day.
I'm working this copper cap.
I've got to get this on here
for part of the decoration.
All right.
Aw, [bleep] damn it!
Crack.
I think I'm going to just
go right to the grinder
and grind it now.
NEHEMIAH BROUSSEAU: Yeah?
[bleep]
[rock music]
The breaking of the
handle's a little bit
of a blessing in disguise.
Well, now I got to to hang
onto that right up to the butt.
The handle was way too thick.
Yay!
I'm glad to be done.
Nehemiah will have it tomorrow.
He will be sharpening
the blade and getting
it completely finished.
Mr. DeMille, I'm
ready for my close up.
ZACK LEWIS: My quench
came out great.
I don't want to be
cocky or anything,
but the blade's looking awesome.
It's got all the intricate
artwork on the steel.
I really did a weird
hammer pattern,
so it looks like it was made
just rocks in the Congo.
I'm hoping to put this
Nzappa zap on the mappa map.
First time using it.
[crash]
Think it'll cut--
probably will "keel."
[dramatic music]
Bladesmiths-- now the
Nzappa zap was a brutal
weapon used in close quarter.
We'll see how lethal
your weapon is
when I deliver multiple
strikes on this pig carcass.
Zack, you're up first.
You ready?
Hell yeah.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[rock music]
[music playing]
Well, Zack, that's a hog.
This is a hog.
It is heavy.
But it's powerful.
The curve you have in here
digs deep into the chops.
Here it lacerated
the spine easily.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Frank-- Nehemiah-- your turn.
You ready?
- Play on.
Play on.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[suspenseful music]
[rock music]
[music playing]
Frank-- Nehemiah--
it's light, so I can
go hog wild on this carcass.
When you dig in, it
cuts into the spine
and into the ribs and
lacerates quite well.
Your Nzappa zap will kill.
The pig that Zack's weapon
had might have opened up
a little bit more, but
the truth is the wounds
were just as deep
and just as bad.
DAVID BAKER: Next up
is the strength test.
Occasionally, the Nzappa
zap was also thrown.
So to test the strength and
durability of your weapons,
I'm going to throw them into
this wooden target three times.
Zack, you're up.
You ready?
Be gentle.
[laughs] I'm never gentle.
[thud]
[music playing]
ZACK LEWIS: Yeah!
NEHEMIAH BROUSSEAU: Aw, huzzah!
[thud]
Nice!
[dramatic musical build]
[thud]
Yeah!
Ugh!
[music playing]
All right, Zack--
it's still tight.
Nothing loosened up.
But right here,
there's a section
of that blade that's just not
as sharp as the rest of it.
There's a roll to that edge,
and that's pretty much right
where it dug in to the wall.
Frank-- Nehemiah--
you're up next.
Play on.
[music playing]
Oof!
[thud]
[dramatic musical build]
[music playing]
You can see right here
when the handle hit
the target in its rotation--
but nothing's wrong
with this blade.
it held up.
Nicely done, guys.
Thank you.
And anybody who actually
has thrown weapons--
you know that the
handles are disposable.
But the metal?
No.
The metal's designed
to not take the damage.
DAVID BAKER: Next up--
the sharpness test.
We're going to see how well
those blade edges held up.
I'm to cut each
one of these ropes.
The meat will drop.
I'm going to cut in each
one of those pieces of meat.
Zack, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
I do you feel like me
and Frank and Nehemiah
are all neck and neck.
It's definitely a
tight race right now.
I've never known what weak
in the knees means before,
but actually my
knees almost hurt.
[rock music]
[music playing]
DAVID BAKER: All right,
Zack, though your blade
is sharp in most places,
that roll you picked up--
I think that's what stopped
it from going through the rope
immediately.
But the second cut--
I caught it down
in here somewhere--
and it just went right through.
All in all, that's a cutter.
Thank you.
Frank-- Nehemiah--
Play on!
[music playing]
[rock music]
For cutting rope-- right
off, this divot in the middle
here actually worked very well.
The handle where it
broke on the throw--
didn't bother me at all.
It's below were my hand sits.
It's a cutter.
Nicely done.
[dramatic music]
WIL WILLIS: Bladesmiths--
what started out
as a competition focused on
masters and apprentices working
together turned into
an apprentice going
against a master
and his student.
You rolled with it,
and here we are.
The judges have made
their final decision,
and the Master and Apprentice
"Forged in Fire" Champion title
goes to--
[dramatic musical build]
Frank and Nehemiah.
Congratulations, you are
the "Forged in Fire" Master
and Apprentice Champions.
Good job.
Thank you.
WIL WILLIS: Zack,
unfortunately, your blade
did not make the cut.
Zack, first let me
commend you for just
pushing through this solo.
Thank you, sir.
DAVID BAKER: You gave
us a lot of artistry
in the forging of your
blade, and that's very
impressive for an apprentice.
But that roll you picked
up in the strength test,
combined with that extreme
weight of that piece,
made it very hard to wield.
And that's why we're
letting you go.
ZACK LEWIS: Understandable.
Zack, you get the
heart of a lion, brother.
Thank you.
WIL WILLIS: But at this time,
I have to ask you to please
surrender your weapon.
ZACK LEWIS: Right now
I'm pretty bummed,
but Jesse ought to be
proud that I persevered
and stuck through this.
Hell, I made it this far, and
I feel like I did pretty good.
I'm a winner in my own heart.
[music playing]
Frank-- Nehemiah--
congratulations.
You are the Master and
Apprentice "Forged in Fire"
Champions.
Good job.
That title also comes
with a check for $10,000.
All right, gentlemen,
please present
your weapon to the judges.
[inaudible]
NEHEMIAH BROUSSEAU: We won!
FRANK ALLEN WREN II: [laughs]
NEHEMIAH BROUSSEAU: Yay!
We were the first Master
and Apprentice Champions.
FRANK ALLEN WREN II: I am
extremely proud of Nehemiah.
Him and I sharing this--
that's what I
really do this for.
I think that the
Nzappa zap that we--
Nzap-- I think that the Nzappa
zap represents exactly us.
And that's why I'm very
happy and very proud of it.
[music playing]